Tatort Deutschland präsentiert den
dunklen Januar jeden Tag ein neuer
Kriminalfall ein tägliches Tatort
Deutschlands Spezial mein Name ist
skadio und ich wünsche euch eine
spannende krimi-zeit
[Musik]
herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland daily dem täglichen crime
Podcast von Bild mein Name ist Toni
Heyer und mit mir im Studio ist Mirko
Kasimir hallo Mirko hey Toni und ein
herzliches Willkommen an unsere
Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer auch von mir
wie an jedem Werktag erzählen wir auch
heute die Geschichte eines wahren
Verbrechens und heute gehen wir dafür
wieder einmal weit zurück in die
Vergangenheit und eins kann ich sagen es
wird blutig sehr blutig
unglaublich blutig es geht um bis zu 650
Morde um mein unheimliches schloss eine
grausame Gräfin und umarme junge Frauen
die ihren blutlos zum Opfer fehlen um
einen Fall der bis heute die Fantasie
anregt und tief in der Popkultur
verankert ist ein Fall der unzählige
horrorfilmmacher Autoren sowie Gothic
und Metal Bands inspiriert hat es geht
um Blutbilder im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes also echt jetzt um das Baden im
Blut junger Frauen um selbst jung und
schön zu bleiben vielleicht aber auch um
einen justizmort und eine politische
Affäre in den Wirren der Zeit der
Reformation wir sprechen heute über die
Blutgräfin
oder wie ihr richtiger Name lautet
Elisabeth bartori geboren im Jahr 1560
in Ungarn nicht weit entfernt von
Transsilvanien na klar wo auch sonst was
Elisabeth Batterie mit Graf Dracula zu
tun hat das werden wir uns auch noch
anschauen aber erzähl erstmal weiter
Mirko
Elisabeth Mutter ist die Schwester des
polnischen Königs Stefan bartori ihr
Vater ein adliger Militär sie erhält
eine gute Ausbildung lernt Latein
griechisch und deutsch schon mit elf
Jahren wird sie verlobt ihr zukünftiger
Ehemann Franz Nador steht von
vogadaschfeld ist fünf Jahre älter
1575 elisabeth ist 14 heiraten die
beiden Elisabeth tritt zum Luthertum
über der Religion ihres Mannes die
beiden leben auf burgschatize Deutsch
schächteds erst zehn Jahre später wird
ihr erstes Kind geboren bis 1598 da ist
Elisabeth schon 38 folgen vier weitere
Kinder von denen zwei die Kindheit nicht
überleben
es ist nicht nur die Zeit der
Reformation es ist auch die Zeit der
sogenannten Türkenkriege das Osmanische
Reich führt Krieg gegen viele
europäische Staaten reiche und
Fürstentümer das königliche Ungarn Teil
der Habsburger Monarchie zählst du den
wichtigsten Schauplätzen des Krieges
Franz Nador steht kämpft schon als
junger Mann kann sich auszeichnen und
macht Karriere in der Armee er kann
mehrere von den Osmanen eroberte Burgen
einnehmen den Osmanen hingegen gelingt
es nie eine von ihm verteidigte Burg zu
stürmen na durch die wird in dieser Zeit
als der schwarze Ritter bekannt wegen
seines dichten schwarzen Bates aber auch
wegen seiner Grausamkeit gegenüber
osmanischen Gefangenen
Ellis Massenexekutionen durchführen und
die abgeschlagenen Köpfe seiner Feinde
in die nächste Schlacht tragen schwarzer
Ritter und Blutgräfin nette Familie auf
jeden Fall während Franz militärischen
rum erringt managed seine Frau die Burg
das dazugehörige Dorf und die anderen
Besitzungen der Familie ein paar weitere
Burgen eine Handvoll Städte Weingüter
Stadthäuser unter anderem auch in Wien
das Paar zählt zu den reichsten Menschen
Ungarns das Haus Habsburg das über
Ungarn herrscht verschuldet sich massiv
bei ihnen um den Krieg gegen die Türken
zu finanzieren das wird später noch
wichtig werden neben ihrer
mustergültigen Haushaltsführung gibt es
aber auch Gerüchte über zahllose
Liebhaber und eine sexuelle Beziehung zu
einer Tante angeblich ist es auch
während der langen Abwesenheiten ihres
Mannes dass sie noch ganz andere Gelüste
entwickelt es heißt sie habe in dieser
Zeit begonnen zum Zeitvertreib junge
Dienerin zu foltern
andere sagen ihr Mann selbst sei es
gewesen der sie auf diese perversen
Spiele gebracht habe nette Familie wie
gesagt aber darüber hinaus ist sie allen
Berichten zufolge eine gute und
liebevolle Mutter
1604 stirbt Franz auf dem Schlachtfeld
doch es ist kein osmanischer Krieger der
ihn tötet sondern eine mysteriöse und
bis heute nicht identifizierte Krankheit
vermutlich eine Infektion
Elisabeth erbt das gesamte Vermögen und
ein Jahr später auch noch das ihres
Schwagers was sie zu einer der
mächtigsten Frauen ihrer Zeit macht
einer Frau mit noch mächtigeren
Schuldnern den Habsburgern
nach dem Tod ihres Mannes so heißt es
lebt sie ihre extremen sadistischen
Triebe völlig ungehemmt aus aus Folter
wird Mord die Opfer sind junge hübsche
Bäuerinnen die Sie zu Dutzenden wenn ich
zu Hunderten gefangen hält misshandelt
und tötet aus purer Lust die Berichte
sprechen von unglaublichen chantaten und
einem perversen Einfallsreichtum der
Gräfen
eins ihrer Opfer so heißt es wurde in
einen Käfig gezwungen in den Stacheln
hineinragten der Käfig wurde sie dann in
die Höhe gezogen und so lange mit Seilen
hin und her geschwenkt bis die Stacheln
des Mädchen zerrissen hatten an manchen
Tagen musste kübelweise Blut vom Boden
ihres schlafgemachtes aufgewischt und
herausgetragen werden so dass die Gräfin
den Boden schließlich mit Asche bedecken
liest der das Blut auffangen sollte
einmal als sie krank war ließ sie sich
eine junge Dienerin ans Bett bringen
Dorothea gentesh eine stämmige kräftige
Bäuerin und seit langem kompliz in der
Blutgräfin hielt das Mädchen fest
während Elisabeth sie wieder und wieder
bis und Fleischstücke aus Wange Schulter
und brustdriss eines Tages ließ sie sich
von einer ihrer Stufen kämmen und als
diese sie dabei unabsichtlich an den
Haaren zog schlug sie die unglückliche
bis das Blut nur so spritzte unter
anderem auf Elisabeth Batterie selbst
verdutzt bemerkte die Gräfin dass ich
Ihre Haut verjüngte dort wo sie vom Blut
der Dienerin getroffen worden war
von diesem Tag an begann sie im Blut
junger Mädchen zu baden um auf ewig jung
zu bleiben okay ihr merkt schon oder die
ganze Sache gleitet langsam ins
Fantastische ab und es ist tatsächlich
schwer hier Fakten Fiktion und
Übertreibungen auseinander zu halten
Werbung kennt ihr das ihr bekommt eine
Schlagzeile aufs Handy zum Beispiel zum
Thema gasumlage und wisst nicht was das
jetzt bedeuten soll die Eilmeldung die
ihr dazu lest macht euch auch nicht
wirklich schlauer dann möchte ich euch
heute einen Podcast empfehlen und zwar
den neuen News Podcast die Informanten
mit Sally Lisa starken und warum heißt
der so ganz einfach sally ist eure neue
Informantin dreimal die Woche ordnet sie
das aktuelle News Geschehen für euch ein
und erklärt euch alle politischen
Hintergründe denn habt ihr euch auch
schon mal gefragt warum in lützeratkohle
abgebaut wird obwohl die Grünen in der
Regierung sind oder warum Abtreibungen
in Deutschland immer noch strafbar sind
und das Gesetz dazu noch nicht verändert
wurde und was bedeuten die Schlagzeilen
von heute für mein Leben sally ist freie
Journalistin und setzt sich für
politische Aufklärung ein in rund 20
Minuten erfahrt ihr von ihr alles was
ihr wissen müsst um mitreden zu können
und das ganz in Ruhe wie von einer guten
Freundin am Kaffeetisch also setzt euch
gerne dazu hört jetzt rein und abonniert
den Podcast jeden Montag Mittwoch und
Freitag gibt es eine neue Folge im
Podcast Player eures Vertrauens
Werbung Ende
fangen wir mal mit dem ich sag mal
populärsten Mythos an den Blutbädern für
die Elisabeth Batterie vor allem berühmt
ist in den zeitgenössischen Quellen
findet sich dazu nichts das wurde ihr
nachträglich angehängt wie auch so
einiges andere die Erfindung der
eisernen Jungfrau zum Beispiel diese
Legende geht wahrscheinlich auf die
Geschichte mit der Dienerin im Käfig
zurück die aber mit großer Sicherheit
auch nur ein Mythos ist nebenbei bemerkt
ist die ganze Geschichte von der
eisernen Jungfrau vermutlich sowieso ein
großer Schwindel angeblich handelt es
sich um einen mittelalterliches
Folterinstrument einen grob
menschenförmigen Hohlkörper mit nach
innenragenden Nägeln oder Dornen
das Opfer wurde hineingestellt und
sobald die eiserne Jungfrau geschlossen
wurde durchbohrten es die Dornen
im 19 Jahrhundert wurden die Eisernen
Jungfrauen gern herumgezeigt um zu
demonstrieren wie schrecklich und
zivilisiert das Mittelalter gewesen sei
und sicher auch um sich an dem Schauder
zu weiden ein bisschen wie die heute
ziemlich beliebten foltermuseen aber
diese eisernen Jungfrauen waren extra zu
diesem Zweck hergestellt worden es gibt
schlicht keine solchen Folterinstrumente
aus dem Mittelalter und auch keine
zeitgenössischen Berichte darüber
natürlich war man im Mittelalter
trotzdem alles andere als zimperlich und
es besteht nun eigentlich wirklich kein
Grund sich angebliche mittelalterliche
Foltertechniken auszudenken wenn man
sich anschaut was Menschen einander
damals tatsächlich angetan haben
womit wir wieder zur Blutgräfin
zurückkommen denn tatsächlich gibt es
zeitgenössische Berichte und verhört
Protokolle über ihr Treiben und die sind
auch ohne Blutbäder und eiserne
Jungfrauen schrecklich genug aber Mirko
erzähl doch mal wie es mit Elisabeth
weiterging
ihr sadistischer Blutrausch wenn es ihn
denn in dieser Form gab erstreckt sich
über mehrere Jahre in dieser Zeit reist
sie von einem ihrer Schlösser zum
nächsten und an all diesen Orten machen
bald Gerüchte über verschwundene junge
Frauen die Runde
am 29.12 1610 stürmt graf-georg torschow
von
Backlights er ist ein ungarischer
Adliger und wohl auch ihr Neffe torjo
verhaftet mehrere Bedienstete allen
voran Dorothea von der wir schon gehört
haben das ist die stämmige Bäuerin die
die jungen Frauen festhielt während
Elisabeth sie folterte außerdem den
Hausmeister Janosch und die Arme Helena
es kommt zum Prozess am Ende werden
Dorothea Helena und Janosch zum Tode
verurteilt den beiden Frauen werden die
vorderen Finger wieder abgetrennt dann
verbrennen sie sie weil lebendigem Leib
auf dem Scheiterhaufen dem Hausmeister
wird wegen minder schwerer Schuld gnädig
der Kopf abgehakt dann wirft man seine
Leiche auf denselben Scheiterhaufen
die Gräfin aber wird lebendig in ein
Turmzimmer in ihrer Burg eingemauert wo
sie qualvoll und einsam stirbt
naja das ist zumindest die Geschichte
die man in denselben Büchern liest in
denen auch von Blutbädern die Rede ist
verbirgt ist dass sie bis an ihr
Lebensende im August 1614 auf ihrer Burg
unter Hausarrest gestellt wurde der
König hatte eigentlich auch für Sie die
Todesstrafe gefordert doch Graf Georg
Torso der sie gefasst hatte setzte sich
darüber hinweg und ließ sie mit dem
Hausarrest davonkommen und jetzt ist es
wohl an der Zeit noch ein paar Worte
über den Prozess zu verlieren und über
die Beweise die gegen Elisabeth Batterie
vorliegen
sie selbst weigerte sich auszusagen
sodass nur die Verhörprotokolle und
Geständnisse der mit Angeklagten
vorliegen und zudem muss man sagen dass
sie sich teilweise widersprechen dass
sie vor allem aber wie damals üblich zu
einem großen Teil unter folterzustande
gekommen sind und so gibt es viele
Historiker und Amateurforscher die
Batterie für unschuldig halten das Opfer
einer Intrige und es gibt einige Punkte
die dafür sprechen als reiche mächtige
intelligente selbstständige und wohl
auch sehr schöne und sexuell aktive Frau
war sie damals per sie verdächtig und
vielen ein Dorn im Auge so etwas war
schlicht nicht vorgesehen und machen wir
uns nichts vor viele Männer haben mit so
etwas bis heute noch ein Problem
noch wichtiger die Familie der batteries
war schon lange mit den Habsburgern
verfeindet das alles begann im Jahr 1571
als sich ein Batterie gegen einen
Habsburger als volvode also Herrscher
von Transsilvanien durchsetzte zwischen
1597 und 1602 holten sich die Habsburger
Transsilvanien zurück kurz darauf kam es
zum Aufstand die Habsburger wurden
vertrieben wieder regierte an Bartoli
den Landstrich man befürchtete dass
dieser Gabriel bartori weitere Feldzüge
unter anderem gegen die Walachei starten
könnte und dass seine reiche und
mächtige Verwandte Elisabeth in mit Geld
Waffen und Männern unterstützen würde
mit ihrer Festsetzung und Entmachtung
war diese Gefahr gebannt und so eine
Intrige war doch viel einfacher und vor
allem billiger als ein Krieg außerdem
hatten die Habsburger sehr viel Geld von
Elisabeths Mann geborgt und ihre
Verurteilung durfte Ihnen auch aus
diesem Grund sehr gelegen gekommen sein
was wir auch nicht vergessen dürfen
elisabeth war lutheranerin die
Habsburger waren Katholiken und bemühten
sich mit der Gegenreformation den
Einfluss der Protestanten
zurückzudrängen war also alles nur eine
Intrige um auf bequeme Weise Schulden zu
tilgen und eine Gegnerin auszuschalten
einiges spricht dafür und vieles dagegen
vor allem die Art der Vorwürfe man hätte
sie wohl eher der schwarzen Magie und
Hexerei angeklagt das war damals weit
verbreitet und allgemein akzeptiert man
brauchte keinen großen Einfallsreichtum
um Menschen in den Kater oder auf den
Scheiterhaufen zu bringen schon einige
ungarische Adlige hatten das am eigenen
Leib zu spüren bekommen warum sollte man
hier eine ganz neue Art von Verbrechen
erfinden und mehr Aufmerksamkeit als
nötig auf die ganze Sache lenken
und so können wir nur mutmaßen was an
den Geschichten von der Blutgräfin war
ist vielleicht hatte sie wirklich
sadistische Neigungen aber hat sie die
Mädchen tatsächlich ermordet vielleicht
waren es
Unglücksfälle ich hoffe ihr hört die
Anführungszeichen die ich hier mache das
Bedienstete geschlagen wurden war an der
Tagesordnung und in einer Zeit in der
sich die kleinste Verletzung infizieren
und einen jungen gesunden Menschen töten
konnte muss es auch häufig zu solchen
unbeabsichtigten Tötungen gekommen sein
wir wissen es nicht die offiziellen
Untersuchungen gingen nach der
Verhandlung und den Urteilen allerdings
noch weiter über Jahre hinweg wurden
hunderte Zeugen befragt wenn man das
denn Zeugen nennen will die meisten
dieser Berichte bestanden aus reinem
Hörensagen und je mehr sie sich vom
eigentlichen Geschehen zeitlich
entfernten desto grausiger detaillierter
und ausufernder wurden sie
bis es schließlich in manchen Berichten
hieß sie habe mehr als 600 junge Frauen
ermordet der eigentliche Mythos der
blutgriffen kam aber erst im 19
Jahrhundert so richtig in Schwung als
das Gruseln in Mode kam und die
angeblich aus dem Mittelalter stammende
eiserne Jungfrau Karriere als schaurige
Ausstellungsstücke machten
1816 schrieb Mary Shelley auf einer
Reise in die Schweiz Frankenstein und er
fand damit den Horror-Roman und Designs
Fiction auf derselben Reise hatte ihr
Kumpel John polydorri die Idee zu einem
Buch namens Vampire das ein wahres
vampirfieber auslöste und ohne dass es
wohl auch Bram Stokers Dracula den
Bestseller über einen blutsaugenden
Grafen aus Transsilvanien nicht gegeben
hätte Dracula geht auf die historische
Figur glatt dem dritten zurück einen
rumänischen Fürsten aus dem 15
Jahrhundert doch es wird vermutet dass
der Mythos der Blutgräfin ebenfalls eine
wichtige Inspirationsquelle war und eins
ist sicher
Elisabeth bartori und ihre mit
Angeklagten starben vor mehr als 400
Jahren doch die Blutgräfin die im Blut
junger Frauen badete um die ewige Jugend
zu erlangen wird in der Popkultur für
immer weiterleben
[Musik]
wir danken euch dass ihr uns in dieses
finstere Kapitel der Vergangenheit
begleitet habt egal ob es nun eine
Intrige war oder ein Massenmord
den Fall haben wir erzählt unter anderem
anhand des Podcasts dunkle Orte der eine
Folge über die blutgriffen hat weitere
Quellen waren die deutsche englische und
tschechische Wikipedia und diverse
Seiten im Internet die sich mal mehr mal
weniger reißerisch mit dem Fall der
Elisabeth Batterie beschäftigen wir
würden uns sehr freuen wenn ihr auch
nächstes Mal wieder dabei seid außerdem
freuen wir uns natürlich auch wenn ihr
diesen Podcast abonniert und eine
Bewertung da lasst bis dann eure Toni
und euer Merkur den traurigen Fall der
Blutgräfin haben wir mit Hilfe des
travel Podcasts Tatort Reise auf den
Spuren der blutgriffen in der Slowakei
so wie Artikeln der Welt nach erzählt
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband
Postproduktion durch die Videos